we are fortunate that under the joe
biden administration dr anthony fauci is
not holding back the actual science of
how things work and
of medical science and we know now
that during the trump administration
there was a friction
that made it to make it very understated
we could call it a friction
it made it so that there was a rift
between the
science of coronavirus and the trump
administration's position on coronavirus
since donald trump left we've been
hearing the science from dr
fauci and the white house has simply
been on board with that and that's a
very good thing
in this vein dr fauci yesterday or the
day before
responded to comments made earlier in
the week by fox news host tucker carlson
which we covered
where tucker suggested that parents who
make their children wear face coverings
are engaging in a form of child abuse
and that if you see a child wearing a
mask you should call
child protective services to report
child abuse the
entire rant was the delusional by tucker
here's just a little bit of it as a
reminder
if you dare to go on foot from union
station to the capitol for example in
washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment how could you
they're saying from behind the gauze how
could you
that's the question we should be asking
of them in return
the rest of us should be snorting at
them first they're the aggressors
it's our job to brush them back and
restore the society we were born in so
the next time you see someone in a mask
on the sidewalk or on the bike path do
not hesitate
ask politely but firmly would you please
take off your mask
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask
is making me uncomfortable we should do
that and we should keep doing it until
wearing a mask outside is roughly as
socially accepted as
lighting a marble in an elevator it's
repulsive don't do it around other
people
that's the message we should send
because it's true as for forcing
children to wear mass
outside that should be illegal your
response when you see children wearing
masks as they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart
call the police immediately contact
child protective services
keep calling until someone arrives what
you're looking at
is abuse it's child abuse and you are
morally obligated to attempt to prevent
it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was gonna get punched
in the face by a teacher
how would you respond to that that's
precisely how you should respond when
they tell you that your kids have to
wear masks on the soccer field
that is unacceptable it is dangerous and
we should act like it because it is
but too few of us have responded like
that so dr fauci was asked about this
and he responded in very clear
and incredibly certain terms
take a listen you know i think that's
self-evident that that's
bizarre uh jim i i don't want to get
into a back and forth
with tucker carlson but i mean it's just
almost self-evident you're talking about
child abuse really come on
now the problem of course is that
anybody who believes tucker to begin
with
is not likely to care what dr fauci says
i've spoken to many teachers because i
have many
friends that are teachers and they told
me you know the last thing we need right
now when we're trying to get
back to teaching is child protective
services
being called by fox news viewers because
the kids are wearing masks
if we are to think of the kids that's
not good for the kids
and then the other thing i've noticed is
kids really don't seem bothered by the
masks like i hate the masks i of course
wear them
but i don't like wearing a mask it's not
particularly comfortable
now that they're not required outdoors
as a vaccinated person i'm no longer
wearing them outdoors but the kids i see
with them and friends who have kids
and they talk to me about it they all
say the kids don't mind it at all
we seem to find it as adults we seem to
find the masks more annoying
than the children i would actually argue
that subjecting children
to tucker carlson's rants is way closer
to abuse than simply wearing a mask
at school and consider the position that
dr fauci has now been in for more
than a year he is a doctor specializing
in immunology
during a global hundred year pandemic
and he ends up thanks to the trump
administration
uh and of sycophants like those uh of
of fox news fame dr fauci ends up in the
position of having to go on tv
to try to disabuse people of the
propaganda that comes
from the former administration dr fauci
goes on tv and has to try to disabuse
people
of tucker carlson's nonsense
disinformation remember that
fox news lawyers stated during a defense
of tucker carlson in a legal complaint
quote no reasonable person would take
tucker carlson
literally it is entertainment it is not
news he uses hyperbole he uses
exaggeration
and it's quite similar to the alex jones
defense of you can't go after alex jones
for things that he says on his show
because he is essentially playing a
character on his show
and certainly no one should take it
seriously jones
or tucker carlson but there are a lot of
unreasonable
people who watch tucker and do believe
it's a news show now my last thought on
this
merely as a curiosity as a thought
experiment
what would happen if someone called
child protective services or even 9-1-1
and said
i'm calling to report that children are
being forced to wear masks
does anyone show up in certain
situations police have to show up if you
call with a certain complaint and then
say
sorry cancel it there are certain types
of things where police have to just go
and check things out
if you call and say children are wearing
masks would anyone even listen to you
or is tucker's suggestion if followed
just destined to be ignored by child
protective services now the other
strange thing about the anti-masters
is that many of them believe covid is a
lab-made bio weapon from china
if you really believed that covid was a
bioengineered bioweapon from china
why the hell wouldn't you be wearing a
mask that again is an example of where
a lot of these anti-science beliefs
conflict when you put two of them
together needless to say
hopefully not that much longer that dr
fauci will need to be on tv refuting
this nonsense maybe that's that's
optimistic thinking i don't know one of
our sponsors today
is sheath underwear the weather is
warming up and as many of us know
that can be associated with sticking
rubbing
chafing with traditional underwear
sheath underwear creates boxer briefs
that solve it
all sheath underwear was developed by a
u.s soldier who spent time deployed in
the desert
he was looking for a way to be more
comfortable and he designed something
that's great
even just for everyday use sheath boxer
briefs have multiple
ergonomic compartments in front
to prevent skin on skin contact keeping
everything
separate cool dry and comfortable so
sheath underwear
will prevent the sweatiness and the
chafing and the readjusting
and sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash
pacman and use the promo code pacman my
experience with sheath underwear
has been great yours will be as well if
you give it a try the link is right
underneath this video don't forget to
use that promo code pacman
for 20 off